[Music]
this summer kayakers are out on the
water once again including in the state
of Maryland but in one section of the
lower Potomac River they're running into
more than natural beauty they find
themselves immersed in history
Mallos Bay is home to an incredible
number of shipwrecks and most of these
vessels didn't end up there by accident
christena Ruffini headed out on the
water to find out more there are ghosts
in these waters phantom frigates that
only reveal themselves when the tide is
right so we're going up between two
shipwrecks this shipwreck on the right
of us a shipwreck on the left and one in
front of us this is called three sisters
Joel Dunn is president of the Chesapeake
Conservancy for almost a century this
ill-fated fleet of wooden steam ships
has been rotting away in the brackish
water of mouth' Bay Maryland it's the
largest collection of shipwrecks in the
Western Hemisphere just in this tiny
base just in this tiny bay and over 90
of them were from World War one and they
were built in an effort to win the war
the vessels were commissioned in 1917
when President Woodrow Wilson needed
more ships to fight back against the
deadly German u-boats the goal was to
build a thousand of them in less than
two years it was a quantity over quality
operation that were built quickly
inexpensively with Greenwood suzhen
Langley is the underwater archaeologist
for the state of Maryland but initially
these were gonna be just expendable and
so they didn't put a lot of effort in
but the war ended before even one of
them made it across the Atlantic
eventually the bad luck boats were
gathered up stripped for Salvage and
abandoned in the bay it's traditional
for a lot of Waterman to take their old
boats up a creek to die and they use the
term to die and they use it as a spare
parts department for years until it
subsides back into the environment the
environment has not only taken the ships
back
it's taken them over plants beavers and
even once endangered Osprey now haunt
the ghost fleet that ship has now become
a wildlife sanctuary wildlife Mecca
it's got plants and animals that are
thriving as a result of the structure
the whole of that ship provides of
course not all the wrecks are so in tune
with their surroundings right behind us
is the Accomack so it's brought here in
1973 and scuttled it's one of the only
metal hull boats that you'll find it's a
litter mentality you know somebody
dropped something then it's okay for
everybody else to sort of do it too in
the same spot and although conservation
and littering don't usually go together
Dunn says here it's smooth sailing the
ships bring tourists who he hopes will
take an interest in preserving the bay
this will bring people to the Chesapeake
Bay get them out on the water get them
inspired to take part to participate we
need the next generation of conservation
leaders and voters the care about the
environment to care about our history a
bit of unfinished business for the ghost
fleet to help resolve for CBS this
morning Saturday Kristina Ruffini nan
join Island yeah mad mad skills from
Kristina there in the kayaking as well
beautiful beautiful pictures